There's a lot of talk nowadays about the
psycho therapeutic use of psychedelics
were kind of going through a psychedelic
renaissance.
It's been a while since the 19 sixties.
These substances have been repressed,
but mankind has been using and
experimenting with entheogenic or God
facilitating substances for Millennia
and there was a great essay written by
Timothy leary that I think is fabulous
piece and the sixties called programming
the psychedelic experience in which he
defined the psychedelic experience as a
period of increased reactivity to
stimuli both from within and from
without.
So there's this increased
suggestibility.
It's almost like we.
We dissolve the boundaries and the
filters that keep us from sort of being
flooded by sense impressions and so one
is it kind of delicate suggestible
state,
so you wouldn't want to be like driving
or having to worry about crossing the
street with a red light or a green light
when you're tripping.
But the psychotherapeutic use of being
in a state of increased suggestibility
is that if you pattern the input
signals,
if you sequence and control what you're
subjected to,
subject it to during this period of
heightened sensibility to stimuli.
You could ski or awareness towards
useful spaces of mind.
You could navigate that evanescent flux
of sensation and perception that Eric
Davis says is all we have and all we are
towards places of ecstatic illumination.
The idea being that you could grab
somebody and give them some high grade
medical cannabis and then lead them on a
hike as they listened to the inception
soundtrack and you could kind of curated
awareness.
You could steer the emotional direction
that people go to.
We are mediated beings.
We are our thought,
our our sense of self is mediated by
language.
It's mediated by environment.
It's mediated by culture and it's
mediated by technologies like cinema and
music and so on and so forth.
But we also are thick skinned beings.
You know,
a lot of the times we close ourselves.
He a capitation makes us less sensitive
to stimuli,
to the mediation.
And so we create higher resolution
technologies,
you know,
four k cameras,
imax movie theaters to create a more
intense mediation that can,
that can,
that can scramble our defense mechanisms
and take us towards these useful spaces
of static illumination.
Childlike sense of wonder.
And so on and so forth,
but those external mediation
technologies need to be accompanied by
internal mediation technologies.
That's why turns Mckenna used to say
computers are drugs and drugs are
computers,
so we need technologies of inner space
to go along with the technologies of the
outer space and the two of them together
I think are pretty cool because they
allow us to experiment with awareness,
with consciousness and to kind of script
or pattern subjectivity.
Eric Davis,
one of my favorite writers is the guy
who talks about this notion that what
we're dealing with with these new media
technologies,
whether they be higher resolution imax
screens or psychedelic substances,
is we're trying to engage the technical
material of subjectivity itself.
Interiority.
We're trying to harness and pattern
interior experience.
We're scripting first person awareness.
It's almost like we become the director
of our own movie from our own Pov and we
get to take it towards the place that we
want.
We get to experience the kind of
evanescent sense of sensation that we
want and that that ideas.
I mean,
it's totally out there,
but how cool is it?
It's like,
it's this.
No,
it's like,
it reminds me of that movie with Arnold
Schwartzenegger,
a total recall where you're able to kind
of become someone else by implanting
the,
the whole unfolding phenomenological
experience,
and so this notion that we could,
we could basically turn our minds inside
out.
You could pattern the human imagination
and sort of turn ourselves into anything
we want and experience any possible
experiences.
Just something that sounds,
uh,
that sounds amazing to me.